das ist echt nichts für schwache nerven
die green er würmer wandern an muskeln
und knochen entlang und graben sich dann
durch die menschliche haut an den füßen
um im wasser ihre larven abzulegen
man kann den wurden nur mit der hand
entfernen und zwar indem man ihn auf
einem stückchen aufrollt stück für stück
eine äußerst schmerzhafte infektion
gegen die es weder impfungen noch
medikamente gibt doch jetzt könnten wir
es tatsächlich schaffen den erreger bald
auszurotten bisher ist uns das einzig
und allein mit dem pockenvirus gelungen
ihr habt euch dieses thema whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
spannenden effekt rund um den bösen
gehen eher warm und die große
ausbildungskampagne herzlich willkommen
bei klicks und science fiction abonniert
den kanal um kein video zu verpassen
[Musik]
ja und den link zum wort für
themenvorschläge und den wozzeck
newsletter den findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung die infektion mit
bakus medien sis so der
wissenschaftliche name des clean air
worms braucht uns menschen zum überleben
als wird also sie wird in nigeria armut
und in mali die krankheit der leeren
kornkammern genannt denn die infizierten
menschen sind so geschwächt dass sie
nicht mehr arbeiten können um ihr geld
zu verdienen die infektionen sind nicht
tödlich doch sehr sehr schmerzhaft und
sie passieren durch ungefiltert das
trinkwasser denn die wurm larven
befallen winzige krebse die im wasser
schwimmen die krebse sterben
doch die parasiten laufen haben ihr ziel
erreicht sie wandern vom wagen aus in
den darm durchdringen die schleimhaut
und paaren sich das männchen stirbt kurz
darauf das weibchen dagegen wandert zu
den menschlichen extremitäten meistens
zu den füßen bis dahin wächst auf eine
länge von achtung bis zu einem meter und
legt dann dort seine larven habe
ungefähr ein jahr nach der infektion
beginnen die würmer sich durch die haut
der betroffenen zu bohren meistens im
bereich der füße und beine und zwar über
wochen hinweg beim durchstoßen der haut
empfindet der wird also der mensch große
schmerzen und so halten die betroffenen
ihre gliedmaßen ins kalte wasser von
seen und flüssen
das weibchen platz schließlich auf setzt
hunderte von larven frei die dann wieder
von kleinen krebsen aufgenommen werden
so also wird das wasser neu verseucht
mit der nächsten generation von larven
ein schlimmer teufelskreislauf also und
genau da setzte der erste ansatz der
wirklich groß angelegten aus kopplungs
kampagne an
die menschen sind dazu aufgerufen
engmaschige stoff netze zu benutzen und
so stand eigentlich der plan den
parasiten bereits bis zum jahr 2015
erfolgreich auszurotten
doch es kam anders als gedacht denn der
wurm war auf einen anderen wird
ausgewichen hunde wohl weil die menschen
schwieriger frieden zu erreichen waren
der genaue hund mensch zyklus ist noch
unklar aber vermutet wird dass sich die
hunde über fisch abfälle infizierten und
die parasiten dann an die menschen
weitergeben indem sie die larven wieder
ins wasser bringen ein fataler
rückschlag für die ausbildungspläne
deswegen wurde als ein zweiter wichtiger
schritt den fischern in betroffenen
regionen an geraten ihre fiche abfälle
nicht weiter einfach wegzuwerfen sondern
sicher zu entsorgen und diese maßnahmen
scheinen wirklich zu fruchten 3,5
millionen neuinfektionen in 21 ländern
wurden mitte der 80er jahre registrieren
absoluter wahnsinn
der grund schlechte sanitäre versorgung
und fehlender zugang zu sauberem wasser
2017 wurden noch und jetzt kommt s 30
fälle bekannt jeweils die hälfte in
äthiopien und im tschad und der wurm
quält uns menschen übrigens schon seit
jahrtausenden sogar mumien wurden seine
spuren entdeckt hauptverantwortlich für
die ausbildungskampagne ist übrigens das
carter center das die initiative zur
bekämpfung des genoms 1986 gestartet
hatte die non-profit-organisation wurde
vom ehemaligen us präsidenten jimmy
carter und seiner frau gegründet der
krasse rückgang der infektion ist eine
richtig richtig gute nachricht denn es
gibt keinerlei möglichkeiten den
betroffenen zu helfen dazu donald
hopkins ein berater des carter centers
es gibt keine impfung gegen den
parasiten und keine wirksame behandlung
daher konzentriert sich die kampagne
darauf sauberes wasser bereitzustellen
und das verhalten der menschen zu
verändern
wie oben schon kurz angesprochen lässt
sich der wurden tatsächlich nur per hand
aus dem körper entfernen die menschen
machen das meist selbst ohne
medizinische hilfe mit einem kleinen
stückchen dort wird ein kleines stück
des wurms etwa zwei zentimeter tag für
tag aufgerollt
wird da zu forsch angegangen reist der
abwehr sind wir schon zombies lebewesen
werden ferngesteuert durch parasiten
darf er hier draufklicken ein wirklich
etwas beunruhigendes video ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran